porta Montes courage says he considered
showing up to test-drive this Aston
Martin dressed in a tux with a martini
in hand and he thought about taking the
car to the Nurburgring circuit were the
big automakers fine-tuned their cars
performance but then he thought
basically this car is made for driving
and so that's what he's going to do von
anka now das village what a tool he
inserts the glass key into the slot in
the dashboard and were an advantage and
430 Aston Martin calls this a sports car
for purists and right away Montes
notices some unconventional details
he says the handbrake is located between
the front door in the driver's seat not
in the center console like in other cars
that creates extra space for the very
high transmission tunnel the bucket
seats offer good lateral support and the
synthetic suede covering in the middle
ensures that you don't slide around when
taking curves fast while the suede on
the steering wheel looks nice montes
finds its rough on his hands enjoy a ton
in hand still it does a good job of
transferring the drivers steering input
to the wheels without any jerkiness as a
result that car feels safe and handles
like a dream here the end 430 makes a
very good impression
yeah Mata says the Vantage n 430 already
sounds pretty loud but you can up the
volume even more by pressing the sport
button along with the sound from the
exhaust this also changes the engine
response making it a little more
aggressive and it already is
well the 4.7 liter v8 engine can deliver
high performance he says you can just
cruise along
it's colorful accents at the end 430
apart from the standard Aston Martin
Vantage aside from the blue and red
paint job buyers can also offer color
combinations
featuring yellow or silver the carbon
fibre details look sharp and also help
to reduce body weight
the cars 4.7 liter v8 engine generates
321 kilowatts of power strut braces
increase the stiffness of the body the
arcus explains that the engine sits
behind the front axle in combination
with the trans axle transmission meaning
that the transmission is in the rear
this makes for more dynamic performance
the Vantage flies from zero to 100
kilometres an hour and 4.8 seconds and
has a top speed of 305 kilometers an
hour Montes says the transmission allows
for short shifts but some muscle power
is needed to change gears the one thing
that bothers him about the gearbox is
that the car often jumps out of reverse
while backing up he says that shouldn't
happen in the car of this class and
Montes has another quibble - he's not so
impressed with the sat-nav from an Aston
Martin he expects something that's been
designed to suit the cars not just taken
over almost entirely from a firm like
Garmin and he finds the controls which
are placed down here behind the
gearshift to be really fiddly you can
only go up and down left and right not
turn and it's hard to get at them when
you're in an uneven gear which isn't so
practical but he says to be fair people
are unlikely to use a car like this for
long road trips where you really need a
Sat Nav and you can always retract it at
the push of a button
inside the quality of the decor and
workmanship are top-notch the mix of
materials which includes leather
synthetic suede metal and carbon fiber
is pleasing to the eye and montes thinks
the and 430 offers a fairly generous
amount of luggage space
there might not be enough room to
stretch out and back here in the trunk
but it's not bad for a sports car sports
body it's this Donnie's little snake the
trunk offers 190 litres of cargo space
the Vantage and 430 has a starting price
of 120 thousand euros in Germany our
test car cost just over one hundred
thirty thousand where their money buyers
get to drive one of the last sports cars
in its class powered by a naturally
aspirated engine
as our this not assess basically the
Vantage n 430 has everything he expects
from a sports car its suspension is
stiff but not too stiff the steering's
responsive and direct and the short
shift transmission makes for quick gear
changes and he adds it has something in
common with other sports cars you don't
really need one but it'd be nice to have
one in your garage